selon Washington il s'agit des chars les
plus performants au monde les Abrahams
des appareils de pointe utilisés depuis
les années 80 par l'armée américaine et
bientôt livrée à l'Ukraine mais d'après
les experts militaires les 31 chars
promis par les États-Unis servent avant
tout un but politique
ce nombre est insuffisant pour faire une
grosse différence sur le champ de
bataille selon toute probabilité il
s'agit du prix à payer pour que les
Allemands acceptent de livrer un
véhicule à l'efficacité comparable le
léopard 2 en bien plus grande quantité
mercredi Berlin a officialisé la
fourniture de 14 léopards de à l'armée
ukrainienne avec les livraisons des
autres capitales européennes 80
appareils pourraient arriver
prochainement sur le sol ukrainien un
renfort de poids pour Kiev capable de se
déplacer à grande vitesse sur 450 km ce
char redoutable permet de percer les
lignes ennemies à son bord les
militaires peuvent et les unités
éloignées sans craindre les mines et les
projectiles à présent la livraison des
léopard 2 n'est plus qu'une question de
temps et nous allons clarifier les
routes d'approvisionnement très
prochainement et je pense que les
premiers chars léopards peuvent arriver
en Ukraine dans environ 3 mois un délai
nécessaire au vu de la préparation et de
la formation réclamée par ses véhicules
une fois les Léopards livrés les
Ukrainiens devront les intégrer de
manière cohérente à leur arsenal
militaire pour maximiser leur efficacité
un nouveau défi pour l'armée de Kiev